how much of playing in the all-star game
is fun and games
and how much of it is nerves for me last
year it was definitely 90
nerves everywhere you look at this is a
superstar
i'm here with demonta sabonis and we are
about to get real de monte's
two-time nba all-star how does it feel
to be back
it feels amazing it feels awesome being
part of this game
with the best players in the nba growing
up as a kid this is all you dream about
you know playing in this game and being
in these
situations all these best players and
now second time in it just feels surreal
you know
just really excited to to be going back
there do you have a pregame routine
that keeps you in check apart from my
nap i always take a nap
that's very important to me that's one
thing my dad said it was uh take care of
your body um he's been through a lot of
injuries so he's like
as long as you take care of her body and
you're ready for games that's half the
battle being available
so i stretch a lot get massages i'm in
iceland 24 7. my teammates make fun of
me
have you had any you know diet changes
throughout last year and this year you
know have you changed what you eat what
you drink
um not really um i remember my rookie
year um i ate ended whatever i wanted
coming from college and then after that
i started uh
trying to eat uh healthier and change my
diet completely and now like
i'm used to it like i like eating
healthy if i don't eat healthy i i don't
feel great so
it's more just it's normal for me now i
know that giving back to your community
is incredibly
important to you why is that um it's
important especially uh
in indianapolis uh you know it's the
pacers and the coats we're the only
top two big teams there and everybody
looks up to you know and the pacers do a
great job of involving all the players
and
anything any ideas we bring up uh
they're always there
willing to match or help out you know
and set up it's been awesome this year
obviously lakova you know the nba has uh
different rules but we're still trying
to do all these appearances or
zoom interviews and and things for the
fans and keep people involved because
that's what makes makes this city the
city yeah absolutely
what is one thing that we should know
about this pacers team we have no quit
you know we're
we're we're going to fight no matter
what you know and it starts with with us
and the coach no matter if we're down 15
or something you know he's always going
to try and uh have us out there and push
for that last
um that last run you know um there's
been games this year where we've been
down big and then we come back and we
win the game that's something that this
group of guys
has had now for a couple years because
we're kind of the same guys that's
something that we're always going to do
we love the game and
we we also have each other's back all
right well again
congratulations on your second all-star
appearance
this was so much fun thanks for joining
us and thank you to volt24
yeah of course thanks for having me